we were talking in the last hour about
foals and Wentz with Steve Mariucci and
what the Eagles can do about it and
instead of me just trying to go back and
forth supposing what it is or going back
and forth with texting he and Rapoport
from NFL Network as I did during the
commercial break and reading to you the
text I forget to just ugly and just
callin right now are you are you there
Ian yeah there's only better something
better than you reading my text on there
and that's me reading my text on there
to do right now okay so so walk me
through it briefly because I know what
you got Freddie kitchens calling in for
your podcast okay the new Browns head
coach walk me through what what happens
here between the Eagles okay in foals so
basically between now and February 12th
I believe 30 days before the week here
the egos have to make a decision do they
pick up the 20 million dollar options
for Nick Foles what basically what that
means is should they give him a one-year
contract worth 20 million dollars if
they do that then Foles has five days to
decide this B give them two million
dollars to buy his freedom so basically
he has a two billion dollar buyback
which is part of the incentives that he
initially and then more than two million
dollars he has a two million dollar
buyback to become a free agent but then
the Eagles have the option of franchise
tag mm-hmm which obviously they wouldn't
use for the 2019 season they would then
try to trade him how would that how it
folds handle that I mean that's not
that's not something I imagine Nick
Foles would want if he's buying his
freedom he wants to go wherever he wants
to go right so would that be would that
sit well with number nine or that
doesn't really matter because the Eagles
aren't just gonna let him go
well the Eagles are going to be very
sort of wary although that's not not as
that's a negative word but they're going
to be very cognizant of his feelings the
perception and everything that it really
like he is a hero you know he is a Super
Bowl hero and MVP soon who rescued their
season twice they're not gonna do wrong
by him and actually I even think there's
some some nervousness about asking him
to pay back two million like even that's
kind of weird like having him pay them
even though it's what he had earned so
the whole thing is sort of complex there
is a possibility they get together and
say alright let's just you know let's
figure this out and maybe they negotiate
a one-year deal that they can use to
kind of trade him maybe today I would
expect them if he's traded or whatever
is traded for fools and the Eagles and
the new team to all kind of work
together to make sure that he's in a
spot that he wants like there's going to
be nothing here that's going to be bad
for Nick close the only thing that's
gonna be bad is for the new team that
would have to give Draft compensation so
just getting him for free or and and the
word wary I think Ian would come into to
play here for the Eagles because it's
possible Falls winds up with the
Redskins I mean what if the what if the
Giants didn't hear from Eli man he made
it that he doesn't want to play anymore
and over the next three weeks and I mean
why wouldn't the Giants want him I mean
certainly certainly if he knows the
division I mean so there's so many
different ways this can go right now and
I'm almost positive I have to look back
at the timing but Pat Shermer was with
the Eagles I think he overlapped with
foals if I have to work it's like when
they I'm pretty sure yes
so one other thing that if the Eagles do
trade him that would be part of it is
they could theoretically have a saying
where he could go
so maybe the Eagles would then say yeah
like we're getting this offer from the
Giant if that all happened or this offer
from the Redskins but this offer from
the Jaguars sounds really nice so we're
gonna take this one can you work with us
on that like that's kind of the the
other part of this which is if the
Eagles so desired they could kind of
steer him in the direction away from the
division which they love him and respect
him so they would obviously think he's a
threat this wouldn't be like trading
McNabb in the Division one
he's done all right and before I send
you to your podcast since I've already
called an Omaha audible on my rundown
and on your day right now what's the
scoop with Antonio Brown across state do
you think right now how's that all gonna
play out too I mean talk about drama on
each side of the state that's going on
with players unbelievable drama and you
know it's hard to imagine I mean I knew
that Steelers were going to talk about
trading I knew that was gonna happen
I knew they're gonna get offers in in
they're probably gonna make up first but
still when Art Rooney said we said it
hit like a ton of bricks
I mean I had random high level and Abela
people go holy cow you just see that
like the owner weighed in and basically
said he's gone and you know we haven't
we've talked a lot about trades and who
doesn't love a good trade you know like
when Marcus Peters is traded he was a
Pro Bowl like that's a big deal when
Antonio Brown is trade I mean he's one
of the best receivers in the NFL we
haven't had this in a long time I mean
this is gonna be you know with Odell
there were just kind of like trade
rumors with Antonio Brown there's gonna
be trade talks and also this is gonna be
a huge huge deal to stop see all right
Ian thanks for the time appreciate it
thanks to the quick callin all right Ian
Rapoport of NFL Media Group at rap sheet
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience